hell-blade sinuous sacrifice is the
latest game from DMC developer ninja
theory and it is a sight to behold
especially running on a PlayStation 4
pro here's a clip from the very
beginning of the game where the troubled
lead character sinua navigates a dark
and foggy land littered with dangers and
rotting corpses it's spooky it's
effective and it's a promising start to
what looks like a fascinating and
disturbing journey be sure to check out
our review for the game when you're done
watching and subscribe to GameSpot for
more hell-blade coverage as it develops
I thought it's not too late to get into
the boat and go no one will judge her no
one will ever know Oh shadows there's no
going back
you can't send our pushes away a world
that conspired to call so much suffering
there's nothing to go back to and worse
to look forward to why don't you join us
maybe you two have a part to play in
this story
usually sli's do not forget my stories
cinema because your darkness comes from
hell and your fate lies there
they say the burning of a corpse will
take you straight to hell as kid but
gods and the living will follow this
path you must leave the aisles of Orkney
across the eastern sea and find a road
that leads north and done through deep
dark valleys after nine nights of riding
you will follow a great river and will
find a bridge covered in gold the path
the Helheim goes from there across the
river of knives but flows from the dark
world and midline
fungus
this time
the land of mists and walk the offal was
right
what was it he said the river of lives
across which lies the halls of hell the
place they call her high
there's no doubt about it just the
source of the darkness isn't a life the
goddess hella holds his salt there
I'd hear beloved
DeLeon
why should why doesn't she talk about
she's doing this for him he's already
dead his song still lives she needs to
say she says it's bad
to the bridge the hell home forget its
name she forgets to but she does
remember they don't either dead may
cross part bad wasn't so easy to forget
the odd fall said that was a hit father
doing
let's see shall we
the Northmen speak of nine worlds the
world of men they called Midgard sky
gods dwell in Asgard the gods of Earth
harvest wind and seeds well in vanaheim
the good Alvis dwell in Alfheim the evil
ones well in Sparta behind the mountain
giant stolen Jotunheim the fire Giants
well in Muspelheim nifflheim is the
world of ice and darkness and that is
where you must travel why did you do
that no this is it the hidden path
I was just hiding find I live longer
that way they call me
truth liar old food is my truth it's
good to see you again you kept your
mouth guide you in this life and the
next
I will tell you my stories of hell if I
may walk with you tell me your stories
again older end I'm listening
the rooms seal the gates to hell
focus your inner eye and you too will
see what's hidden in plain sight she
needs to focus now hold it in your
mind's eye find one like it to open the
gate
it's near focus you will find it
look towards the gate
the Gators go through the gate go
through it it's dangerous I spent six
years and slaved in hell if I watched
the Northman learnt their ways I know
you did you listen when everyone else
left my prize
carry my stories with you and together
we will make the Northmen feel our fury
join us
she was try to make them go away they
wanted around
Oh
I guess it's the same with Heights